hi everybody my name is Anita and I'm
currently leading gen growth and
education here at vum and over the last
few years we worked with hundreds of
companies who have successfully deployed
reliable AI Solutions in production from
simple to more advanced agentic
workflows one thing became very clear
those companies who have adopted a test
driven development approach were able to
build reliable and stronger systems for
production today I'm excited to share
how you can apply that same approach to
build your own effective agentic
workflow that actually works but before
we jump in let's take a step back and
truly understand how we got here in the
first place I'm so excited to get
started let's do it so let's go back to
2023 everyone was building AI rappers
and most people argued that there is no
defensibility strategy around them and
fast forward to today we have cursor AI
which is the most popular and wildly
used AI powered IDE that just hit 100
million AR in just 12 months this is the
fastest growing SAS in the history of
SAS so why and how did this happen
because models got better at coding sure
because AI adoption skyrocketed that's
absolutely correct because coding was an
obvious first Target that was supposed
to be disrupted by these AI models there
is no doubt about that but more
importantly we built new techniques and
patterns on how how we can orchestrate
these models to work better sync better
with our data and then work effectively
in production we rely on these
techniques because there are clear
limits to model performance
hallucinations is still a thing
overfitting is still a problem and
developers needed more structured
outputs and while model providers
started to ship better tooling to Sol
for all of this we didn't see another
lip similar to the lip between GPD 3.5
and gp4 these big jumps started to slow
down and for years making models bigger
and fitting them more data kept making
them smarter but then we hit a wall no
matter how much more data we added these
improvements started to slow down and
models started to reach their limits on
existing test but is this true did we
really hit that wall seems like there
were some other avenues and new trining
methods that we still haven't explored
and so let's see what happened next so I
don't really think that there is an
issue here because since then and this
happened in the last two to 3 months
we've seen some new training methods
that push the field forward for example
we got the Deep seek R1 model which is
the first model that was trained without
using any labeled data we call this
method real reinforcement learning and
this means that this model was able to
learn on its own reportedly this is what
open used to train their reasoning
models like 01 and 03 and all these
reasoning models today they use Chain of
Thought thinking at inference time or at
response time to generate their answers
in turn allowing these models to think
before they give an answer to our
questions it enables them to really
solve more complex reasoning problems on
top of this we're seeing all of these
model providers to provide more
capabilities to their models like use of
tools more capabilities for research um
near perfect OCR accuracy when it comes
to the Gemini 2.0 Flash and really
expand the field forward however
traditional benchmarks are so saturated
so people are starting to introduce new
ones that will really capture the
performance of these new reasoning
models for example The Benchmark that
you're currently seeing on the slide
here the humanities last last exam it
measures performance on truly difficult
tasks so if you check the table on the
slide you can clearly see that even the
latest very smart models struggle with
these challenges so yeah models are
getting better the field is moving
forward but for an AI product that
actually works in production success
isn't just about the models anymore it's
about how you build around it and that's
exactly what's been evolving in parallel
to model training so we were learning
how to prompt all of these models better
and we developed more Advanced
Techniques like Chain of Thought then we
thought that we should be able to ground
all of this models responses using our
own data so rag became an important part
of our workflows then we learned that
for multi-threaded conversations memory
is going to be the most important thing
that we've had long context from the
latest models enabled new use cases then
we started to think about hierarchy of
our responses so we started to
experiment with graph rack and then just
lately we're thinking about using all
this reasoning models that in fact will
take a lot more time to think in real
time however it also develops new areas
and use cases that we can develop and
lately we're thinking about a gentic rag
making our workflows even more powerful
so that all this can work on its own and
the field is still evolving but even
using these techniques isn't enough you
need to understand your problem deeply
and take a test driven development
approach to find the right mix of
techniques models and logic that will
actually work for your use case and this
actually brings me to the main first
topic of this presentation test driven
development for building reliable AI
products because the best AI teams that
I've seen follow this structured
approach they start to experiment then
they evaluate it scale then finally when
they deploy in production they never
stop stop working on their workflow they
capture all of those responses to then
continuously monitor observe and improve
their product for their customers let's
look at what you can do at every stage
of this process before you build
anything production grade you need to
experiment a lot you need to prove
whether these AI models can actually
solve for your use case so you should
try different prompting techniques for
example fuse shot or Chain of Thought
some of these will work great for simple
tasks and other will help with a bit
more complex reasoning you should test
various techniques prom chaining is
usually very uh well received because
it's going to work better if you split
your instructions in multiple prompts or
you can adopt a more agentic workflows
like react that will have a stage to
plan and then reason and refine before
it actually gives you an answer what is
really an important part in this stage
is that you need to involve your domain
experts um because Engineers shouldn't
be the ones who are tweaking prompts uh
and bringing all these experts will
actually save a lot of your engineering
time because once you do this phase
right then you will actually have a
proof that this works and that
engineering time needs to be involved at
this stage you should also stay model
agnostic uh you should incorporate and
has different models and especially when
it comes to your use case you need to
think about Which models can do the job
better so in such case you can um maybe
use some uh different uh models like
Gemini 2.0 flash which is actually
really well at OCR uh and something that
we've seen work really well lately so
let's say that at this stage you know
that U these AI models can actually work
you have a few examples that these
models have like really good performance
on but how can you test whether this
will actually work in production when
you will potentially have hundreds if
not thousands or millions of requests
per minute and so this is where
Evolution comes in in this stage you
actually create a data set of hundreds
of examples that you're going to test
your models and workflows against and so
at this stage you need to uh try to
balance quality and cost and latency and
privacy and you're definitely going to
make a lot of tradeoffs because no AI
system is going to get all of this
perfectly but for example if you need
high quality maybe you can sacrifice
speed if cost is critical you might need
some lighter and cheaper model and this
is the stage where where you need to
Define your priorities because it's
always better if you define your
priorities earlier in the process you
should use ground through data where
possible if you want to evaluate all
these workflows having your subject
matter experts design these databases
and test these models and workflows
against is going to be very very useful
synthetic benchmarks help however they
will not really evaluate these models
for your own use case so it's usually
very very powerful if you can use your
ground through data but don't worry even
if you do not have ground through data
you can use an llm to evaluate another
model's response this is actually a very
standard and reliable way when it comes
to evaluating your
models very importantly at this stage
you should make sure that you're using a
flexible testing framework no matter if
you're building this in house or if
you're using any external service your
AI isn't static so your workflow should
also be dynamic it should be able to
capture all of this different
non-deterministic responses you need to
be able to Define custom metrics you
need to be able to write those metcs
metrics using python or typescript so
you shouldn't be looking at a very
strict framework customizability is a
very big thing here and then finally you
should run evaluations at every stage
you should have guard rails that will
check internal nodes and whether these
models are actually producing responses
at every step in your uh workflow
actually producing responses that are
correct at every step in your workflow
and then you should also test while your
prototyping but then you should also
utilize this evaluation phase to come
back once you have some real data but
how are you going to get some real data
so let's say that you evaluate your
workflows extensively with your subject
matter experts with your data that
they've created and let's say that
you're now satisfied with the product
that you have so you're ready to deploy
it in production so once that that
happens what do you need to do is your
job done here when it comes to AI
development you need to monitor more
things than deterministic outputs you
need to log all llm calls you need to
track all of those inputs and outputs
and the latency because AI models they
really they're really really
unpredictable so you need to be able to
debug issues and understand how your AI
behaves at every step of the way and
this is becoming extremely more
important with a gentic workflows
because gentic workflows are more
complex workflows that can take
different paths in your workflow and
make decisions on their own you should
also handle API reliability you need to
maintain uh stability in your API calls
you need to have retries you need to
have fallback logic to prevent outages
for example two months ago open AI had
four hours of downtime so if you had a
fallback logic in your productionize
solution then your um AI will know to go
back to another model and use another
model instead you should definitely have
Version Control and staging and you
should always deploy in control
environments before you roll out to The
Wider uh public because with it when it
comes to AI you need to be care careful
that once you update a prompt you're not
introducing a regression to another
prompt or part of your workflow so you
need to ensure that all these new
updates they won't break whatever you
have in production and the most
important part here is that make sure to
decouple your deployments from your
scheduled app deployment schedule
because the chances are that um you will
need to update your AI features more
frequently that you will need to update
your app as a whole so make sure to do
that and so let's say that now you have
deployed you're starting to capture all
of your responses from your users and
create a feedback loop to identify edge
cases that you capture in production to
then continuously improve and make your
workflow better you can capture all of
these then run evaluations again and
test whether um new prompts that you
develop will solve for this new cases
you should also think about building a
caching layer because if your system is
handling some repeat queries caching can
drastically reduce costs and improve
latency so for example instead of
calling an expensive llm for the same
request multiple times you can store and
serve frequent responses instantly and
this is something that is a standard
these days when it comes to building
with AI and finally let's say that your
product has been running reliably in
production for uh a longer period of
time time that you feel comfortable to
then go back to that data and use it to
fine-tune a custom model that will um
basically uh create better responses for
your specific use case uh can reduce
Reliance on API calls and in fact can
work with lower costs and so this
process is becoming even more important
than ever when it comes with agentic
workflows because these workflows are
going to use a wide range of tools they
will um call different apis they will
have multi-agent structures that will
execute a lot of things in parallel so
when it comes to evaluation with a
gentic workflows and with this test
driven approach it's not just just about
measuring performance at every step in
your workflow because you also need to
assess the behavior of these agents to
so that you can make sure that they're
making the right decisions and following
the intended logic and this year more
than ever everyone is talking about
agentic workflows but what does that
actually mean uh I would love to talk
more about how you can build all this
agentic workflows but I'm not here to
give you the perfect definition of what
an AI agent is and instead I'm going to
try to Define different agentic
behaviors and some different levels on
how um they can be built so if you think
about it every AI workflow has some
level of ener gentic behavior in it it's
just a question of how much control
reasoning and autonomy it has so we've
looked at the past the present and where
we're headed and from that we put
together this framework where we Define
four or five different levels of gentic
behav Behavior I'll go into more details
on each level but keep in mind that this
is not a final framework it's not set in
stone as models evolve this can expand
the things can blur and um a lot of
things can shift but for now this will
give us a way to define where we are
today and what we expect to see next at
this stage you have an llm call you
retrieve some data from your vectory
database and then you might have some
inline evals and finally you're going to
uh get some response from this workflow
so you can notice that in this workflow
there's no reasoning planning or
decision making Beyond what's baked into
the prompt and the Model Behavior so the
model is doing all the reasoning here
within the prompt itself and so there is
no external agenda organizing uh the
decisions or planning some actions
however there is some reasoning and some
agentic Behavior at the models level and
so if we move from l0 to L1 we can see
that in this stage our workplace can now
use a lot of tools and so this EA System
is no longer just calling apis it no now
knows when to call them and when to make
those actions and so this is where we
start to see more gentic Behavior
because the model can decide whether uh
it will call a specific tool or whether
it will call our Vector database to
retrieve more data before it actually uh
generates an output memory here starts
to play a key role because we're going
to have multi-threaded uh conver
conversations and then uh all of this
will potentially happen in parallel so
we need to capture all context
throughout the whole workflow evaluation
is also needed at every state uh step of
the way here because we need to ensure
that this models are making the right
decisions using the right tools and
returning uh accurate responses but this
workflows can be as simple as on the
slide right here or even more
complicated where you're going to have
more different branching happen uh
happens at every stage in this workflow
where you can have 10 different tools
and the agent needs to reason whether
it's going to call the first five or the
or the last two and so this is uh where
again we see a lot more agentic Behavior
but L2 is where we actually see that um
these workflows now move from simple
tool use which is not in many cases it's
not a simple tool use like the previous
workflows can be very complex but now we
see some structured reasoning this work
workflow will notice triggers it can
plan actions and it can execute tasks in
a structured sequence so this means that
it can break down a task into multiple
steps it can retrieve some information
it can decide to call another tool it
can evaluate its usefulness if it thinks
that it needs to be refined at that
stage and once it does this in a
continuous loop it can generate the
final output but um you can notice that
atic behavior here starts to look more
intentional because the system isn't
just calling the tools that are listed
uh for their use it's also actively
deciding what needs to be done and
spending more time to think what needs
to be done instead of just deciding
whether a tool should be called and so
at this stage um one part is that the
process is still finite so once this
workflow completes the steps um as it
plans to complete them it will terminate
rather than it will run continuously but
it's a Leap Forward
um from just calling uh tools and so uh
L3 however is where we see more autonomy
where we see more uh decision making
that are not um defined by us as the
creators of this workload so the L for
system can proactively take actions
without waiting for direct input so
instead of responding responding to a
single request and then terminating this
one will stay alive and will
continuously monitor its environment and
it will react as needed so for example
um this means that it can uh look at
your email slack Google drive or any
other Tool uh external Services actually
that you can give access to and it can
plan its next moves whether it will
execute actions in real time or asks uh
the human for more input and so this is
where uh our AI workflows become less of
a tool and more of an independent system
that we can use to truly make our work
easier so for example this one can be
like a marketer that will prepare this
video or a presentation that you can
just take and use whenever you want
however the final stage is where we're
going to have a fully creative workflow
and so at L4 the AI moves between uh
Beyond Automation and reasoning and it
becomes an inventor so instead of just
executing predefined tasks or just like
reasoning within some bounds um it can
create its own new workflows so it can
create its own utilities whether it's
agents prompts function calls tools that
uh it needs to be designed uh it will
Pro it will solve problems in novel way
so well true L4 right now is definitely
Out Of Reach because there's some
constraints with models like overfitting
because models they really love their
training data and there is some issues
with uh inductive bias where models will
make assumptions again based on their
training data this makes to be like a
very hard task ask uh today but that's
the goal AI that doesn't just follow
instructions but will invent it will
improve and it will solve problems in
ways we didn't even think of before so I
would say that L1 is where we're seeing
a lot of production grade Solutions so
at Bellum we've worked with companies
like redin dra and headspace all of
which have deployed production grade AI
solutions that fall within the L1
segment and again like just using tools
it can be very simple or it can be very
complex workflow uh the focus is though
on orchestrations how do we turn our
models to interact with our system
better how do we make our models to work
with our data better how do we make sure
that whatever we retrieve from our
Vector databases is the right and
correct context for the uh question that
the user is asking and so like we're
experimented with different modalities
and all of those techniques that we
mentioned before and test driven
development truly makes its case here
because like you need to hack different
tools and models and you need to be able
to continuously improve on them to build
not only a more efficient system But A
system that will work continuously
better and better um however L2 is where
I think we're going to see most
Innovation uh happen this year and this
is where we're going to have a lot of AI
agents that are being developed to plan
and reason using models like 01 or O3 or
deep sick uh we might see a bunch of
different use cases we might see a lot
of Innovations when it comes to the UI
and the ux part of the system where we
will definitely create some new
experiments experiences for users and um
essentially this will be uh a way for us
to make true reasoners that will handle
complex tasks so you're going to have
bunch of these agents just working for
you doing uh different things however L3
and L4 they're still both limited by the
models today as well as the surrounding
logic however however that doesn't mean
that uh there's a lot of innovation
happening within those two as well so if
you want to learn more about how to
build your own uh AI agent I've included
everything that I've shared in this
presentation and more for example uh
architectures that you can build what
are the stages that you can test and
similar things like that we also feature
top researchers and professionals who
have shared all of their learnings on
how to build these for production so
feel free to scan this QR code on the
screen to download this resource so now
I think it's time to get more practical
I want to show you how I built my own
SEO agent this specific agent automates
my whole SEO process from keyword
research to content analysis and finally
for Content creation it decides whether
to use tools and has an embedded
evaluator that works on an Editor to
tell the agent if it's doing a good job
let's see a quick sketch of how this
agent works so in a minute I'm going to
show you a real demo on how this agent
actually works however I wanted to give
you a high level overview on what are
the steps that this workflow will take
and so when you look at the sketch on
the screen right now you're going to
notice that this workflow lies between
L1 and L2 type of agentic workflow you
have the SEO analyst and the researcher
who will take a keyword and it will call
Google search and it will analyze the
top performing articles for that keyword
one it will identify some of the good
parts uh Within These articles that we
also need to amplify in our own article
but it will also Identify some missing
segments or areas of improvement that we
should definitely write about to make
sure that our article is actually
performing better than the ones that
we're competing against and then after
the research and planning is done the
writer has everything it needs to start
writing the first draft what then the
first draft is passed to the editor
which is an llm based judge that will
evaluate whether the first draft is good
enough based on predefined rules that
we've set in its prompt then that
feedback is passed back to the rouer and
this will Loop uh continuously until
some uh criteria is met uh within this
Loop we also have a memory component
that will capture all previous
conversations between the writer and the
editor and finally we're going to get a
final article that's actually a very
useful um piece of content that it's not
a generated and not useful but truly
using all of this context in a Smart Way
enabling me to have a pretty impressive
first draft to work with so now let's
see the demo for the sake of time I'm
going to start running this workflow as
I explain what this agent does at every
step in the workflow so we ran this
workflow with the keyword Chain of
Thought prompting and so the SEO analyst
currently is taking that keyword is
taking some other parameters like my
writing style like the audience that
we're trying to cater to and it analyzes
the top articles that Google is ranking
for that specific keywords it tries to
identify some good components from those
articles that we need to reinforce in
our article but it also identifies some
missing opportunities where the
researcher is going to utilize those to
then make another search and capture
more data to make our article be better
than the articles that we just analyzed
so now that the SEO analyst uh is done
with its job the researcher tries to
capture more information about the
things that um were previously
identified as missing pieces to the
puzzle and then the writer will take a
lot of this information in its input and
it will try to create a great first
draft using that data as context so the
content here that will be generated by
the writer it's not going to be like a
slop type of article it's not going to
be something that it's really not useful
it's going to actually use all the
context that we're sending from
different articles that we just analyzed
you can also connect your rack here that
it will look into your database of
Articles and learnings and it can really
create something that's extremely useful
now the editor says okay this is a good
enough article but here's some feedback
and so it passes the feedback through
the memory component here which is a
chat history between these two and then
um this node that uh basically
structures that input for the sake of
this demo the conditional here for the
loop is that this Loop will break if the
evaluator actually tells us that this is
an excellent post which actually rarely
happens so um we also said that if the
loop runs for at least one time this
Loop will break and so it already ran
for one time we got still more feedback
from the editor but in this case for
this demo let's look at the output that
we got so mastering Chain of Thought
prompting in AI a comprehensive guide
for developers I think it's pretty okay
pretty nice I might change the title but
I know that the components this article
are the actual components that other
articles are writing about and so uh
this was great the latency was around
118 this usually takes around 300
seconds to run when we have more
evaluation Loops but it's pretty great
it gives me some foundations on how I
can continue to build on this content
and it saves me a lot of my time so the
product that I just used is called
Bellum workflows and it was designed to
bridge the gap between the product and
Engineering teams so they can speed up
AI development well still following this
test driven approach that we talked so
much about in this presentation however
one thing became clear developers want
more code developers want more control
and flexibility and they want to own
their definitions in their codebase so
today I'm excited to introduce our
workflow SDK it provides all the
building blocks you need it's infinitely
customizable and it has a
self-documenting syntax where you can
actually spot how this agent is working
right in your code it's also also
expressive enough so that you can
understand what's happening at every
stage in your code the best part is that
the UI and the code stay in sync so
whether you're defining debugging or
improving your workflows everyone on
your team can stay aligned I hope that
you like it it's open source and free
and you can check it out on GitHub feel
free to run uh to scan this QR code uh
to check out the repo and that's a wrap
thank you so much for listening and I
hope that today you learned something
new if you want to talk more about AI I
feel free to scan this QR code on the
screen to connect on LinkedIn or if you
have any questions feel free to um send
me a text message on my email or on
Twitter I'm GNA follow up for sure